Nicki Minaj is coming to be the judge of
the first episode the new season of drag
race Nicki Minaj goes to nothing but the
Met Ball Young Money
my name's might sell Nicki doll I've see
you well you are doing me proud what
kind of um what kind of judge is she is
she like a Ross is she a Michelle she's
a combination of both she understands
the artistry and how much work it takes
to go into it but she's also she's not a
pushover
she really lets you have it if she sees
that there's something you could have
done better she lets you know you look
like a Barbie out of the box show up and
make her spirit boom the new cast sort
of young and like exciting what can
people expect what's different what's
the same well each season it's different
because of the personalities that come
to our show
you know we of course and the producers
try to trick them up because a lot of
these kids grew up watching our
television
yeah and they think they got it but we
do our best to try to shape it
I'm here to play the competition Sheree
is a big loud Broadway Dame we are the
best things in the world but I'm the one
to be you know at our efforts core our
show is about the tenacity of the human
spirit and all these kids were little
boys who were may have been bullied or
we're told by society you cannot do that
but they persevered and they did and
they didn't let what people have to say
deter them so they come with strength
and courage and imagination and stick
with us so that's always entertaining to
watch and that's why I love drag queens
and celebrity drag race is coming what's
it like working with those celebrity
haha you know it's so funny just when
you think that celebrities all right
they have it together and they're so
secure you really hate when they get
into into drag they're a little insecure
you know you find out that there are
some insecurities that you have to you
know power through so they understand
that you know there is this thing of
perseverance and and really pull it
through at the last minute and
everything might not go perfectly but
you got to make it work you know and so
that's one of the challenges of being on
drag race I mean it's an intense intense
thing with the celebrities it's
interesting to see someone who's never
been in full-on drag to perform because
drag doesn't change who you are actually
feels you are right I love this so much
ha Jamal Sims my dream everyone's like
you're going to Vegas for RuPaul and I
was like it was amazing thank you well
this is like the Super Bowl it's just
better than football
yes it's so fabulous
[Music]
for people who may not be fans of drag
race they don't exist but um explain
what you've brought to Las Vegas what's
a little live version of our television
show and Jamal who has been part of our
television show from the very beginning
is the perfect choice to you know direct
the show and choreographic do the whole
all the footwork why Vegas right now
well I love Vegas Vegas is such an
American phenomenon it is so fascinating
and you know it's always been a dream
hug Jamal and I worked together in Vegas
26 years ago at the Sahara Hotel
I had a review there and this was a very
um you know a pared down tail down a
little bit me and two dancers Jamal was
four that's it yeah I was actually a
banker it was this must be dancing and
bad girl but I think they might have cut
my mic off
[Music]